are you doing today I'm Jake well thank
you
Congrats on being part of the show it's
so well done that I've recently binge -
both seasons yeah
did you seen the first season prior to
being involved no I hadn't and I watched
as I mentioned it and I just I loved it
I thought it was brilliant and then when
I started working on Sirius - and I've
actually seen the whole series finished
I think it's even better than series 1
so you know not often do you have a
series that's that great that then gets
even better so I am very excited by it
one of the things that strikes me about
the show is that Chuck Laurie's writing
he's so good and it's honest and real
and it doesn't rely on these sheets that
certain shows rely on to you know push
the plot forward can you sort of talk
about the dialogue and in his work yeah
it's very interesting because it's the
kind of comedy that does not play this
comedy at all it's played as absolutely
real drama and of course if you think
about it that's what makes it funny
because because in real life you know
real situations are actually can be
looked at as being hilarious I mean like
you know meeting someone you you fell in
love with 50 years ago at a funeral I
mean it's the circumstances that makes
it that makes it work so well but his
writing is brilliant and of course
working with fantastic actors I mean
every single person in that shows
amazingly talented so it's just it's a
joy and and he's right there he he
doesn't miss a beat he's right there
behind the camera watching and writing
the next one he doesn't write it in
advance he writes it as he goes that's
interesting I did not know this no and I
didn't either because I said what's the
arc he said I don't said well he said
III think you're gonna be in two
episodes that's okay and then after I
did my first scenes
yeah he's called my agent said no no
she's gonna be in five so that was good
I like that
okay I have so many questions which I
figured there was script looking I have
to know so you so you really don't even
know so how does it work in terms of
filming well no you know you get your
script but you don't know what the next
scripts good to be and he doesn't
necessarily because he's writing it
while you're shooting the other one so
what's brilliant about it and I think
why it's so offend
taken so great is that as the characters
grow in the scenario that he's given
them it it actually tells him where he
wants to go next with those characters
it's like real life it's like what
happens and wonder what would happen to
them next oh I think this might happen
to them and how would that impact them
oh that's how would it impact them so
that's how it goes that's why it's so
brilliant that's so interesting did you
ever submit with shows they will be on
episode six and then realize oh we need
to pick up on Episode two did that ever
happen not to me not to my knowledge not
with me I'm so fascinated by this
process because it's so unusual yeah no
one works like this so how did it work
in terms of did you have like a what
does he write a script over like a night
I mean how does that I think so and and
from what I gather he writes everything
right that's everything and he's writing
like fight shows at the same time you
have to understand not just one show and
he's like running and watching the
others being shot at the same time guys
genius
no I there's a reason he's Chuck Lorre
there is a reason he's gentle oh yeah
completely um you have been in so many
projects so many shows and movies I'm
curious when people see you standing at
like a Starbucks what do they always
want to talk to you about or does it
depend on which Starbucks I would say
it's either you know kitty cat wedding
crashes or it's James Bond if I'm in
England they're still obsessed yes cuz
I'm British pretty much anywhere in the
Midwest it would be dr. Quinn Romania
definitely dr. Quinn I mean it's the
only film only series they saw after the
you know the the government changed that
was the only television they ever saw so
literally I go anywhere near Romania I
am literally pursued like to a degree
that you can't even imagine
and France they play doctor Quinn in
France all the time and then there are
people who loved East of Eden and of
course the Jewish community loved war
and remembrance and and then a scarlet
pimpernel Oh somewhere in time what can
I tell you and usually and always men
that is not a chick flick General Colin
Powell took me aside and spoke to me for
hours because his favorite film ever
he's watched 15 or more times was
somewhere in time do not tell me
the three-star general is check because
yet tough back that's amazing that III
have to go but I can't imagine when
people are for making a beeline to come
to you you're probably thinking what
what just the project what are they
going to bring more at least that's
anyway well you know it's usually I
would say top top the list be the summer
in time wedding crashes or or docked
quit Congrats on being part of this
project it can be Kaminsky yeah listen
it's really so well done thank you so
much for your time thank you